[Music]
the whole is a stable iquilibrium of all
the parts and each part is a spirit at
home in this whole spirit which does not
seek its satisfaction outside of itself
but finds it within itself because it is
itself in its equilibrium with the whole
the secular Librium can it is true only
be a living one by inequality existing
in it and being brought back to
equilibrium by justice justice however
is neither an alien entity remote from
this whole nor more the reality unworthy
of the name of justice of mutual malice
treachery and gratitude etc which would
execute judgment in an unreasoning
arbitrary manner by misunderstanding the
context of the action and by
unconsciously acts of omission and
Commission on the contrary it is the
Justice of human law which brings back
into the universal the elements of being
for self which is broken away from the
balanced whole that is the independent
classes and individuals it is the
governments of the nation which is the
self affirming individuality of the
universal essence and the self conscious
will of all the justice however which
brings back to equilibrium the universal
and its ascendancy over the individual
is equally the simple spirit of the
individual who have suffered wrong it
has not split up into two the one who
has suffered the wrong and an entity in
a remote beyond the individual himself
is the power of the netherworld and it
is his ear anis his fury which wreaks
vengeance for his individuality his
blood still lives on in the household
his substance has an enduring reality
the wrong which can be inflicted on the
individual in the ethical realm is
simply this that something merely
happens to him the power which inflicts
this wrong on the conscious individual
of making him into a mere thing is
nature it is the universality not of the
community but the abstract universality
of mere being and the individual and
avenging the wrong he has suffered does
not turn against the former for it is
not at its hands that he has suffered
but against the latter as we saw the
consciousness of those who share the
blood of the individual repaired is
wrong and so
to weigh that what it simply happened
becomes rather a work deliberately done
in order that the mere being of the
wrong its ultimate form may also be
something willed and love something
agreeable
there is a lot here going on in
paragraph 462 and what Hegel is
sketching out for us is particularly
fascinating because he is finally coming
to this question of justice and we're
going to see that justice has multiple
sides to it and is supposed to somehow
encompass multiple sides at once so
there is almost in certain respect a
mirroring of the equilibrium of
equilibrium that's taking place here at
a lower level and I'll say why it's a
lower level in just a moment so I do
want to start off by talking about this
notion of the whole he talks about the
whole being a stable equilibrium of all
the parts and each part is a spirit at
home in this whole a spirit which does
not take it satisfaction outside of
itself but find it within itself because
it is itself in this equilibrium with
the whole so in that very first sentence
there's already a lot to be unpacked and
let's begin with this notion of whole
and part another way in which we might
translate gone in this case is the
totality and what do we mean by the
totality well we have the way that Hegel
is depicting at a community which is
essentially a closed unit if we want to
use per minute D in language you know an
unbounded seer right
encompassing everything it is the range
in which meaning can arise and develop
and be worked out by individuals in
their relations with each other so it's
the whole earth the totality and then he
says that this is a stable equilibrium
we'll come back to that notion in just a
second but notice what else he's saying
here that each one of the parts in a
certain sense reflects the
hydrati of the whole or the totality of
the other parts that it is connected
with and we want to think about well how
does this how does this actually work
well think about the the ways in which
enculturation works where an individual
who is you know it's just considered by
themselves essentially a meat machine an
animal right the rationality that we
have as human beings it's something
where Hegel is on to a very important
point the rationality that we have as
human beings is not a rationality that
would be totally estranged from and
prior to any culture or community or
even family relations altogether to be
rational is to be at least in an
incipient way social to be engaged with
others not just the other of you know
say the master-slave dialectic or the
struggle for recognition but others in
so many other determinate ways the ways
in which we ourselves encounter people
the things we can remember how how
indeed we were brought up in the
families that we were the schools that
we went to the friendships that we had
the clubs that we were members of and
perhaps left behind the larger community
that we took part in institutions that
we either were drafted into or
volunteered for like going into military
service or engaging in some other
similar commitment so I mentioned we
would come back to talking about this
stable equilibrium that then is an
important point
strictly speaking equilibrium might not
be the best way to convey what's being
said here because the German term for it
which we can translate as equilibrium
the quote you know quite frankly like
victi kite saying that each of the
things has a similar weight now we can
have equilibrium because what we
do is we balance everything out and very
complicated manners so that the center
of gravity is in the middle but this is
actually saying so that this term is
actually saying something here at the
lexical level that each of these member
parts has an equal importance and equal
weight they wouldn't necessarily have to
mean that if it were not for the fact
that Hegel then begins talking about
inequality and the need for justice so
what is the weight it's not physical
weight of course it has to do with how
people are treated and what they're
allowed and what they allow themselves
to do so he says this equi Librium can
only be a living one this is a point
that we made a little bit earlier an
equilibrium can only be a living one a
vital one a dynamic one if there's some
movement within it and the movement
within this is in terms of value
inequality comes in right inequality
arises in it and then the equilibrium is
restored by the workings of justice now
Hagel is not going to try to provide a
complete you know full substantive
definition of justice at this point he
will however tell us what it isn't and
that's quite important so we'll look at
that in a moment but we should first
think about this
what does justice do justice takes the
unequal that shouldn't be unequal
because sometimes inequality is the way
things ought to be and it fixes it in
some way perhaps not entirely and not
the same way in every single
circumstance for every type of case but
it adjusts things it it brings things
back into an equilibrium for the parts
in this case the parts of the ethical
whole that is the society what isn't
justice
so here's what a Hegel tells us justice
is not it's not an alien entity remote
from this whole so it's not something
coming in from the outside say you know
a divine revelation this is justice you
must follow these laws and only if you
do so will you be just or is it people
like say justified or made righteous
Hegel is not saying that that's the case
there is of course the element of divine
law but that's not involved here yet
what else isn't justice justice is not
simply what we might call you know a
equilibrium of self-interest or
transactional justice the way that he
puts it very great phrase here I think
it is not the reality which he
acknowledges this is in fact a reality
unworthy of the name of justice however
of mutual malice treachery ingratitude
etc which would execute judgment in an
unreasoning arbitrary manner justice is
not simply those who have the power
balancing each other off and engaging in
reprisals to keep anybody from getting
too big for their proverbial britches or
those sorts of things
oftentimes that gets called justice and
when we think about the way that the
administration of justice or criminal
justice works within our societies we
are in fact confronted with many cases
like that where we see discretion turn
into arbitrary exercise of authority
simply the suit ones you know passions
of fear or desire or anger or you know
whatever else that's not justice
according to Hegel that can actually
sometimes have an effect of restoring
some equi Librium or reducing certain in
justices or inequalities but that's more
or less an accidental you know
success he goes on and he said that this
kind of justice that is not really
justice would misunderstand the context
of the action and by unconscious act of
omission and Commission would execute
judgment in an unreasoning arbitrary
manner so it cannot be you know justice
sort of just as transactions by whoever
happens to have the power or who gets to
speak it cannot be just arbitrary
judgments made on the spot there has to
be something more to it so he goes on
and he says on the contrary it is the
Justice of human law which brings back
into the universal the element of being
for self which is broken away from the
balance hole what is he talking about
there he'll tell us in just just another
you know sentence but we should cause
why do inequalities that call for
justice arise they don't arise just
because people say man I want to screw
it somebody else I'm going to take what
they got well sometimes that does happen
right they arise in part because
subjects human beings human persons
think that doing something that perhaps
they may not even realize is producing
an inequality of disequilibrium a jar to
the system is best for them to do they
see that as what is advantageous or what
is reasonable for them to do and they
act accordingly why do they do that
because they are caught within this
logic of the being for itself now let's
let's think about what Hegel actually
says here who are doing these sorts of
things he says
the element of being for self which is
broken away from the balance hole what
is that the independent classes and
individuals it is very possible for
individuals because of you know there's
sort of shortsightedness
and the fact that they can't read
everybody else's minds to not be
cognizant of how their own actions and
choices and commitment are affecting
other people you know the person who
years and years ago
you know enacted some some particular
policy within his or her apartment
building that would affect the way the
tenants lived and just made the
decisions about you know what to put in
in terms of renovations may have screwed
over their tenants without realizing it
and it may be necessary at some point to
say hey this needs to be addressed and
the person you know may be tempted say I
acted in good faith I did everything the
way I should or they may say well
everybody does what's good for them and
and that's if they may be much more
bald-faced about it we can also talk in
terms of classes when it comes to this
stable equilibrium of the whole what's
the case when we have classes of people
who think that the way in which they're
living is indeed what they're entitled
to and if it affects other people
negatively well screw them or well
that's unfortunate but there's nothing
to be done about it or we can go on and
on and on well this happens all the time
in society after society after society
and the administration of justice is
something that addresses that we see
this occurring throughout history
particularly with class dynamics as one
class becomes more important in power
another class starts to decline feels
threatened it insist on its prerogatives
finds other ways to glom on to what's
going on there meanwhile the lower
classes are quite often you know being
screwed around by the play of these
other classes justice should be
addressing that he says so what is going
to be able to do that he says if the
government remember we've talked about
this before the ruling apparatus of the
nation if the government of the nation
he says
which is the self-affirming
individuality of the universal essence
and the self conscious will at all
now this is a bit of an idealization of
course right the government doesn't
always turn out to be the the self
conscious will of all sometimes there's
there's a bit of will of one or will of
a particular class being involved and
this is a real issue that Hegel is going
to address now he goes on and he says to
justice which brings back to equilibrium
the universal in it the sentence eo2 the
individual is also something else it is
also the simple spirit of the individual
who has suffered wrong this is what
often gets left out of the picture and
doesn't get addressed by the human law
which is looking at the whole society
and trying to restore some sort of
equilibrium that works out better for
the whole the individual can get lost in
the shuffle as we say or fall through
the cracks we have all these wonderful
metaphors that have to do with you know
losing sight of you know the determinate
individual who has actually been wronged
we see this all the time in criminal
justice settings when people are saying
look policy you know dictates that we do
this and then criminal rights people are
like listen these people did this stuff
to these people and that needs to be
somehow brought back into the picture
so what Hegel tells us is is this the
Justice does not split up into two the
one who has suffered wrong and an entity
in a remote beyond the individual
himself is the power of the nether world
the wronged individual sometimes the
wronged individual can take action on
his or her own account sometimes they
require something else to happen so you
know he talks about the individual is
the power of the nether world and is his
Irenaeus his fury with wreaks vengeance
Irenaeus punished offenses they're part
of the divine law in traditional Greek
mythology you see this reflected in
the stories of the playwright's right so
he goes on and he says his individuality
his blood lives on in the household his
substance has an enduring reality or
doesn't this is what is up for question
in the actions of the household he goes
on and he says the wrong which can be
inflicted on the individual in the
ethical realm is simply this now notice
what Hegel says here that something
merely happens to him when a person is
not being treated as an individual one
aspect of that is that their personhood
their agency is being ignored and the
agency of what happens to them is also
being reduced to the natural or the
necessary or you just happen to be in
the wrong place at the wrong time buddy
you know it's unfortunate that you got
shot in the drive-by but you know they
were shooting for these other gang
members and you just happen to catch a
bullet by being in the wrong place at
the wrong time or it's unfortunate that
the tax laws ended up working out the
way that they did they're really working
great for the majority of the nation and
they kind of screwed you nothing
personal about it it's just the way
things are and we can come up with
example after example after example here
Hegel talks about this in terms of a
power that's inflicting the wrong on the
conscious individual turning them into a
mere thing this power is as he says
nature and he says it's not the
universality of the community instead it
is the abstract universality of mere
being this is something that can happen
with justice and it's administration the
administration of justice by the
government can turn into treating human
beings as mere beings and it happens all
the time and it's a tragic situation
because it's rather difficult to avoid
now in this case the family on the part
of the wronged individual seeks out some
some justice of its own and he says in
avenging the wrong that he has suffered
the individual does not turn against the
community for its nodded at hands that
he has suffered but against the ladder
the abstract universality right and
nature so he goes on he says as we saw
the consciousness of those who share the
blood of the individual repair this
wrong in such a way and now notice
what's going on here why don't you
actually read the passage animal is a
really important reflection repair the
wrong in such a way that what is simply
happened becomes rather a work
deliberately done in order that the mere
being of the wrong its ultimate form may
also be something willed and that's
something agreeable we often hear people
who are opposed to you know doing
something about some sort of inequality
or some sort of crime or some sort of
damage that has taken place say well you
know if you do that that you know
measure you enact that law or you give
that person that judgment it's not going
to bring back whatever is the case it
won't bring back the dead child it won't
you know give them their career back it
won't it won't it won't and and this is
like a litany
what Hegel's saying is yes of course it
won't that's not what's at issue
what's that issue is what happened to
the person and whether that can be
humanized whether that can be turned
into something that means something
rather than just you know one more case
of a person being ground up within the
wheels of necessity because you see the
social world is a world of all sorts of
necessities but it's also a world in
which we think and engage with others so
it's not necessarily you know to bring
back the the individual or to have them
vicariously when say for example a
candlelight vigil is taking place where
a murder
or where somebody was gunned down
you know unjustly by the very mechanics
of justice that we're supposed to be
protecting them they're not trying to
say well you know the individual lives
on people do say this sort of thing of
course but Hegel would say that's kind
of nonsense what you're doing is you're
restoring back to that person the
dignity of being a person and that's
about as much as you can do and if the
community as a whole really understands
what it means to be a community oriented
by justice it will be in favor of that
however that's not going to always be
the case and we're going to see tragic
situations arise where justice in two
centers is going to clash with each
other
the ethical realm is in this way in its
enduring existence in immaculate world a
world unsullied by any internal
dissension similarly its process is a
tranquil transition of one of its powers
into the other in such a way that each
preserves and brings forth the other we
do indeed see it divided itself into two
essences and their reality but their
antithesis is rather the authentication
of one through the other and where they
come into direct contact with each other
as real opposites their middle term and
common element is their immediate
interpenetration the one extreme the
universal self conscious spirit becomes
through the individuality of the man
United with its other extreme its force
an element with unconscious spirit on
the other hand the divine law has its
individualization or the unconscious
spirit of the individual it's real
existence in the woman through whom as
the middle term the unconscious spirit
Rises out of its unreality into actual
existence out of a state in which it is
unknowing and unconscious into the realm
of conscious spirit the union of man and
woman constitutes the active middle term
of the whole and the element which
sunders itself into these extremes of
divine and human law it is equally their
immediate union which converts those
first two syllogisms into one in the
same syllogism and unites into one
process the opposite movements one from
actuality down to unreality the downward
movement of human law organized into
independent members to the danger and
trial of death and the other the upward
movement of the law of the nether world
to the actuality of the light of day and
a conscious existence of these movements
the former falls to man the latter to
woman
in paragraph 463 Hegel is bringing this
entire section to a very strong close
talking about these these two sides
these two extremes that are connected by
a middle term he's also going to employ
the language of syllogism which might be
a little bit misleading here because
he's not arranging things in actual
syllogisms we would have to read that in
and I think that would be a bit of a
distraction at this point now he tells
us that the ethical realm is in its
enduring existence and immaculate world
a world unsullied by any internal
dissension now he's just talked about
how that's not the case for the ethical
substance so how is this granted to work
out he says its processes a tranquil
transition of one of its powers into the
other in such a way that each preserves
and brings forth the other how is that
going to happen the linchpin here is
going to be this middle term which he's
going to tell us is the union of man and
woman so what we've got going on here is
something ideal not actually conforming
to the real that he's just discussed in
terms of how justice plays itself out
but what we're shooting for so he tells
us this we see the ethical realm divided
itself into two essences in their
reality but their antithesis is rather
the authentication of one through the
other and where they come into direct
contact with each other is real opposite
their middle term and common element is
their immediate inter penetration so we
have a mediating middle term and you say
well what is that mediating middle term
Hegel says it is they're very relation
to each other the relation between man
and woman and on both sides something is
going to take place but it's going to
take place through the mediation of the
other in this middle term so it's a
little bit complex what he's saying here
but I think that's probably the best way
to understand it he says the one extreme
universal self conscious spirit
through the individuality of the man
United with its other extreme is forced
an element unconscious spirit that is
where the divine law is taking place the
family the community which is
understanding itself is grounded in
unconscious spirit and we're going to
see how the unconscious play a major
role as we go on so on the other hand
the divine law has its individual or the
unconscious spirit of the individual's
real existence in the woman who adds the
middle term the woman is functioning as
a middle term the unconscious spirit
Rises out of its unreality into actual
existence out of a state in which it is
unknowing and unconscious into the realm
of conscious spirit so how does the
unconscious become conscious through the
woman but not just a woman per se but
the woman related to the man just
similarly the man related to the woman
it can be a middle term so he tells us
that this middle term is the union of
man and woman right it's unders itself
into these extremes of divine and human
law then he talks about syllogisms and I
would say at this point don't worry too
much about that but what we want to
focus on these upward and downward
movements what is the the downward
movement he says there's a downward
movement from human law into from
actuality down to unreality the human
law organized into independent members
to the danger and trial of death now
that might think make you think back to
the self-consciousness section and the
struggle to the death go ahead and think
about that but also think ahead to
what's coming up in the section yet to
appear and the where we're going to see
two brothers square off against each
other right and then there's an upward
movement as well from the divine law
coming upward into actuality and
conscious existence both of these are
made possible by the mediating term of
the the woman and the man and the
mediation that is connecting
both of them in the end of this section
you